before that though davonte adams
uh br breaking yeah his silence he
hasn't said much in recent weeks not
many packers players have said much
since the otas ended he had some
interviews that he did a while ago but
now he's saying that the aaron rodgers
situation
is not something that the packers
players talk about it's not something we
truly talk about like that everybody's
been dialed into what they've got to do
there's enough to worry about
themselves than to be going and worrying
about what other guys are doing and what
their situation is like especially when
we can't control
any of that and i know some people react
to that by saying oh baloney of course
they're talking about it
but you quickly get to a point yes where
there isn't
anything to say they're not in the news
gathering dissemination and analysis
business for them
they probably get sick of it real quick
if there's nothing new there's nothing
to talk about
right yeah exactly right you know i
think you you said it right if it's not
in the news cycle or some of it hasn't
been flushed out
you know or or whatever they're not
going to talk about it like i'm sure
there was a lot of chatter
you know when the draft pick happened
and jordan love
and guys sending text messages and
having some quiet you know conversations
in a private place in the locker room
about like can you believe they did that
and all that
of course they're having like little
conversations this off season here and
there
but like i think what devante adams is
saying to what you're saying it's not
consuming them
they're not like all in the having a
gossip party in the locker room during
otas a few weeks ago talking about like
man what do you think will happen next i
heard roger said this
and i heard gutenku said that so it's
not that way
you know when you walk into an nfl
locker room hey on a day like that they
probably looked around
davonte adams probably asked the
receiver hey do you see 12 and they said
nope and then they just go on okay we
got a wide receiver meeting in 15
minutes
we got to go in there and you start to
go into football mode and just worry
about yourself and what you got to do
for the day
do you think devonta adams has asked
aaron rodgers point blank
will you be here for camp and do you
think rogers has told him
uh yes i do think he's probably asked
him point blank
and yes i do feel like rogers has told
him now rogers i think
i don't know maybe not yeah i would i
would think that happened
yes i yes i don't know adams isn't gonna
say
what his conversation was with rogers or
anything like that
but man i would have a hard time
thinking like
if it's peyton manning and marvin
harrison or
you know brady and wes welker or you
know
and and not to that i could speak to
this but just a little like if it was me
and joey galloway in my one year of
starting as a quarterback
and if i had that type of issue if he
called me in july or
june and was like hey man i mean you're
still going to be there in training camp
i'd probably you know hey yeah i'm going
to give them a little bit more of a hard
time but i'll be there man i'm going to
be there yeah
i would think that conversation has gone
down between two guys who have pretty
good chemistry and relationship
and it makes sense right i mean think
about any other job think about this
here if there was some issue that you
had or i had
and it wasn't clear whether one of us
was gonna still be around at some point
there's gonna be a conversation yeah so
the other one who is directly affected
by the presence or absence of the other
will have an idea of what the hell life
is going to be like and when you're
talking about
being the guy who catches the footballs
that are thrown by the quarterback
there is a definite and urgent need to
know
what i'm going to be doing yeah do i
need to go hang out with jordan love
over the next six weeks and get more
acquainted with catching passes for him
do i need to get together with aaron
rodgers and you know we've heard nothing
about any of that stuff either and maybe
they're all being very quiet
but you know even if aaron rodgers
doesn't want to show his face in green
bay and even if he wants to send some
sort of message to mark murphy brian
guticun's whoever
this is the time that we're slipping
into where quarterbacks and their
receivers will make time to get together
to just polish some things up so they're
ready to hit the ground
running at training camp we've heard
nothing about rogers getting together
with
adams and the rest of the receivers
right or jordan love getting together
with adams and the rest of the receivers
well
i would think that we would hear
something like that here in the next
like two weeks for sure like someone out
of the rogers camp
or one of these receivers lets it be
known
unless you know i unless rogers wants to
play some game still to where he doesn't
want that released
i don't know did maybe just still make
guten coost and mark murphy
you know uncomfortable and still not
knowing what he might do but i mean at
that at that point i mean i just that
that seems like games and unnecessary so
i would imagine that we hear something
like that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports